[Music]
good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv
and movie channel
i'm joined as always by the nath
is frozen
oh am i frozen still
a little bit
isn't it always great how it pauses in
the best faces
i will i will remove your second young
harrison
yeah and get you back in he's still
frozen
and obviously stormy bear is with us as
well so we'll wait for harris to come
back
today we are going oh is he hello
he'll be back
right so we are going to be talking
stargate today we're going to be talking
series three
and reviewing the marvellous series and
then discussing a little bit about
maybelline because you know this is this
is a there's a couple of really good
episodes in the series with may born in
and you know we have to ask is really he
is useless as he looks hey harris is
back yeah okay
so yeah
but he's back so grand uh we're gonna
have one of those technical issues days
aren't we
damn
yeah not for me this makes it stressful
for me
but anyway so
um before though we get into discussing
stargate as always we'll discuss what
we've been watching this week so
stormy we've been watching this week
nick before we kick off okay so
the thing i've been watching the most is
the uh outcome of all of my covert tests
which is still all positive i've gotta
collect i'm building a collection
uh harris thinks i should make a
popsicle stick boat and sail to hawaii
with all of them it would be great
i've had a lot of down time
uh there's one thing
i found called archive
archive
it's about it's a it's a series that in
the future
about storing people before they die
i really can't say anything else
because it's such a
i don't want to spoil the ending because
the ending is tremendous but it is
called archive
you know i suggest that heart of it very
very good tv
and there's not a tv show to me i think
i might have seen it advertised but i've
not watched it so i will keep an eye
open for that it is a little bit on the
cerebral side
you know
it is really really i mean it's not an
action thriller you know so it's not
that
also watch pray
the hand ringing
that went on before you know a 95 pound
girl can't take off well if you really
watched it the whole tribe had a stab at
the
predator i mean he got cut up one in and
down the other
you know and she was the
last last hunter standard you know and
she just
outsmarted it used its own technology
for me it was just it was a remake
predator
but i think it made more sense in a way
because the predator ignored her
for a lot because she was a 90 pound she
wasn't a threat so he that's that's why
she survived to the end
in the original predator
arnie just survived because he was lucky
that was the only reason arnold's the
mass man standing he just happened to be
the one the predator went for last and
then he happened to fall in some mud
and the predator let's all remember
killed itself
i mean essentially you know
i mean he said that you know he set his
self-destruct when he was suicide ernie
really didn't kill the predator suicide
the predator suicided himself
in that correctly right yeah yeah yeah
he suicided himself here
he harvey weinstein
i think that one
it's the other one it's the other stein
back there now
i was going with jerry but i think
harvey's next
i think you're gonna get eight now this
week
another thing i was watching
uh i was kind of surprised i just
watched an episode on a lark
and started watching pennywort
the butler for batman
um
singer that's in it i think she's great
i can't remember her name because she's
more poppy but she's so funny
um
if you spoil this thing i will come over
there and i will punch you in your
covered face
i'm i'm so enjoying it it's so good and
i'm i'm just
episode six
it's a blast it's fantastic don't forget
the bonus episode
yeah eleven episodes i might see no i've
watched season no i've watched eight
i've watched eight
so um oh but it's oh it's so good um
it's so beautifully made and even i
didn't like the guy that plays the
sandman in the first episode i thought
he was a bit crap and i couldn't
understand why he was whispering oh it
was going to work
by the third episode it's like
freaking love this guy he's amazing he's
really enjoying it
um so yeah don't spoil it
okay so i also got got around to finally
seeing
uh top gun maverick there we go
i like i really didn't like the way they
did
val kilmer
yeah yeah i like that
all right
apologize for stormy by the way guys if
you think he's really not very well
but he's going to do his best for us
today but
he loves psytrack so much
that even half dead with code
how about you that's what you've been
watching this week sir
oh well um oh sorry no storm he's got
one still you can wait the turn stormy
well now he's had time to watch and of
course you know leading up to this i've
been uh binge watching stargate sg1 this
week and i'm up season five
uh uh
we just one thing i want to bring up
especially in season one
we were we were talking previously on
another live stream concerning um
when did um
new daniel jackson start you know
getting away from the original actor
when did he stop doing the impression
yeah
right and we also discussed you know
when did uh
uh jack o'neill become the sgsu one
jaclyn you know and
about um
jax dealing with his
uh dead son
which was introduced in the original
movie and how he died and that theme is
brought up more than i remember
you know i think um
son charlie
and
excuse me
i was really touched with and you could
and i think we were right that it wasn't
necessarily
we got to see the original jack not the
traumatized jack from the first movie
you know
because we see that play through
with scarra scars abduction etc etc and
finally scars yeah
and we see
and i think
and it was the same thing with daniel
jackson of how you know dealing with
we'll talk about that in a minute stormy
because
you've always
well i too have been catching up on a
little stargate we're not catching up
i'm still watching it for the first time
ever but uh i i just went to the movie
last third of season three and i'm about
three or four episodes into season four
so i'm having a good time with it right
now uh
we'll get into all that in a little bit
because i'm kind of i hit the sweet
spots for this week thankfully uh
but i i saw beast i know you recently
saw a beast but i started beast today
last weekend and then
this past week i've seen
uh i also saw interest i've seen edges
open twice in the theater this week
because i went to go see george miller's
3 000 years of longing and uh
that was good it was it's very vibrant
and has a good charm to it but it's not
blockbuster worthy didn't make nearly as
much money as i expected it to
sorry george miller uh bring us more mad
max please uh
but um
besides that i watched the samaritan
and then
i saw something else in the theater oh i
went to see the invitation which was not
the best horror movie in the world but a
horror movie nonetheless it was a good
time
i'd love to be a teenager again and go
to cinema every day as soon as you've
got family kids
out in the world
i decided to go to the cinema and just
like i've got a
job
i said the one thing i did watch this
week that i was um i i in my car driving
home after watching it i ranted in my
brain actually quite out loud for a
little bit because i did that um i
watched the second episode of she-hulk
okay um
and i loved that spoiler alert on this
one tim roth is in it uh as the obama
and and he's great he's such a great
actor and he's really good in it and i
love
but his acting in it is great because
he's just he just pulls back from
sarcasm when he's saying how sorry he is
and he sort of does it
you know he's just
it's that hint that he's he's talking
[ __ ] but then he's talking about hikers
and things i think the high queues were
great
yeah i'm still not a fan of the humor i
still think it's a bit and breaking down
the fourth wall and all that stuff i'm
like a bit
okay you've done this um
but
i'm just waiting for daredevil to turn
up
um
but it did it it just threw me back
to
um i'm i'm still so angry what they've
done with the hulk and they've made them
the intelligent hulk
and they did it off screen
between the two avengers movies you know
we had that whole story arc where he's
the hulk won't come out and he's scared
of thanos and he's like come on big guy
help me and then go
and then there's just between the two
events
sorted figure that out
um
it's a little irritating at times but on
the whole i'm quite enjoying it but i'm
just going to die yeah i think the first
episode had a little bit of that but the
second episode i thought was just was
good for anybody and everybody i i liked
the second episode a lot more it did
lean into the humor a little bit but uh
yeah as long as it's gonna go uh love
and thunder type of humor i think we'll
be all right
jesus christ that's comedy vomit
everywhere
but
let's have a chat about stargate series
three it's why we're here people
um even though stormy's already already
ran to the end
first of all let's just talk quickly
about what our general feelings of the
series because i'm going to tell you
straight off the bat i think this is one
of the weakest sg1 series
as a whole
um
there's a lot of
quite boring episodes in there for me we
can go through a couple um but
uh what do you guys think is it as a
general series compared to the rest
where do you rank it where do you write
it
well
i saw that there's great series in here
in this country
leave me alone they're also picking on
me like he's like say seriously that's
what we say to you
it seemed to me that it was kind of a
act
you know
others um there was a lot of you know we
got a lot of really
juicy detail world building in season
one
and then in season two we got to expand
it a little bit more detail and i think
the detail phase kind of blew it over to
season three
season four really starts to expand on i
mean you know at this point in time how
many damn times have we killed us
i told you he was dead
then he had like the molten skin face
you know reincarnation when he was in
hell or whatever
and uh
[Music]
i think there was a lot of sprouts that
went really that led to very strong
episodes and uh seasons after that
but i think i mean three was good it was
okay i mean you know i'm not throwing it
out or anything but
uh in terms of how we were spoiled after
this
yeah really excellent storytelling and
several spin-offs
i think three was
if it ended there i think three would
have been a really great season
but we really got spoiled with really
great ships on down the line that came
from season two and season most
definitely it laid the seeds what's
harris you are a newbie a a baby
stargater
you only series one two and three so how
do you think it compares to one and two
well
just just starting i guess season four i
see what y'all are saying with season
three kind of lacking a little bit just
because it immediately moves faster in
season four
um but i i like season three just coming
from a fresh perspective at the same
time i'm a sucker for some world
building so those slower episodes that
kind of draw out and build the mythos i
don't mind as much
but they don't necessarily progress the
story forward as much as season one or
two did i
probably tied for season two is
my least favorite as of now just because
season one was just great just to
introduce everything but season four
already
i think i think i'm gonna really like
what's going forward i already like it a
lot but i think what i'm really going to
like what's going forward because of the
setup
there's a lot
i love it
i i think season four is the probably
the best season
of all of them if i had to pick one
um it's so strong um i actually think
season two is probably the most
important season out of all of them
season you see i can play good
um and um i can play nicely with the
americans
um
because because it like sets everything
up in season two but season three so but
we will talk about a couple of the
episodes
for me the start of season three is
mind-numbingly boring i hate to have
four episodes into fire i think they're
stupid
um i hate the hathor character full stop
and um and and i just think it's crap
but this is basically how we ended this
season two review conversation
this is [ __ ]
um
so can we ignore that and move on
if we can also ignore the second episode
which is set
it's also crap okay so okay
yeah um i like the fair game episode
though with the treaty i like that
episode yes um
do you want to know a little bit of
stargate trivia that i learned that i
found fascinating
characters
the characters of nerdy and you
um
had both worked previously on stargate
the pair of the actor that played you
is was actually a stuntman
uh on stargate sg-1 before this and
nerdy her character she was actually a
um a screenwriter
so she a story editor sorry so she'd
actually worked previously on stargate
and they just gave her a job they were
literally like
who will fit in this outfit you'll
think about that do became a a major
character really
they did this a lot in stargate though i
mean that chap that yeah um he was the
tall fellow he was always an engineer so
with glasses and he was actually the
stunt coordinator and he appeared in
loads and loads of episodes
um because they just sort of like seemed
to get pushed on something like what
lauren said the camera
but um but i didn't know that first time
so i love that
i love the episode fair game looks it
also told us a bit more about
um
the
the asgard and it teased
where they were going with the end of it
when they said we are fighting an enemy
that is far worse than a gold and we're
getting our asses kicked
um in another galaxy um so it teased
where we're going with the end of series
three
so yeah but um we each picked an episode
and that we really liked if it's okay
with you gentlemen i'll i'll go first
that's okay
um i loved the um dead man switch
episode
with um with sanjay jones in uh he's
it's an eric an actor that i
you know obviously we know him for
flash gordon's alive
um obviously he was flash gord but in
this he played our spock and he just
he's just that that bounty hunting
character i wish he'd come back in other
stargate episodes because it's not the
best star star game episode in the world
don't get me wrong um but i just loved
his character and i just wish we'd seen
more of him
yeah i mean we didn't we didn't really
add much to the series to be honest this
episode but it was he was just great in
it
um and yeah i wish he'd been i wish he'd
made a comeback i wish we'd seen him a
bit more
um
harris which episode did you pick sir
i chose nemesis which is the
season finale and
i don't know that was it might not have
been my favorite episode of the season i
don't know if i could choose a favorite
i really did like the heir spock episode
because that's just
good world building but subtle world
building all at once
but nemesis was great because it
kind of brought all the world building
that we've gotten
a good chunk at least of the world
building we've gotten so far too full
circle we get to see
the new enemies of the asgard we get to
see kind of thor open up even more so
than he has to
not just uh jack but also carter and
teok a little bit
so
i was i was just a really big fan of the
episode and
i liked i liked the it was it was really
sci-fi you know really specifically okay
we have to blow up the ship heading into
the atmosphere
the pressure won't do it up here or down
here
different things the vacuum of space
would screw it up we have to do it right
here we have to be hyper specific
teal combo is dying and having to be
flown off the side for a little bit and
thought back in the ship that's great
always dies
almost always guys
thankfully he's a jafar
daniel actually dies and comes back teal
almost dies a lot
actually i think in season five he did
die
after uh apothis brainwashed him and
braytax stole his stole junior ripped it
out of his tummy and then
they all had to watch him die so he
would um
get rid of the brainwashing
and start seeing the prophet says
but then he came back that's what they
thought on that
they all start in that treatment don't
they that um that that chemical
treatment that the top crush the blue
yeah the blue man
yeah the blended
blended worms
sorry hey george how are you doing
um
and bob and everyone's in the house and
andrew yelling at me for season
um so
and stormy sorry what video what episode
did you pick as your is the standout one
for you
i really like shady regret i mean we
discussed this um
on a private chat really when i started
this event um we're not talking about
your adult movie collection we're
talking about
these concentrates
how many shades of grey
uh this was uh apparently it was one
just
when i prepared when i prepared for
stargate sg1 for my binge i was reading
this book
the egyptian book of the dead
the way of the cartouche
i got more
oh god they're down here
do way more research than i think is
necessary yeah i know i didn't know
jackson
yeah i was really i was really into it
you know once you read this there's a
whole lot of storytelling they just took
from this book i mean this is actually
the egyptian book of the dead
and in terms of storytelling
i'm really really um
inspired that the writers
went to such historical detail to write
all of the series
but in terms of which shade of gray
it was mabel you know this is the
episode where
jack o'neal goes to the toll and they've
got this uh diplomatic conference about
um technology
especially weapons
and uh jack becomes all indignant
leaves flash of anger rips a sensor off
the wall to
i don't know
to show his uh disdain for the tollins
and then he becomes a real major [ __ ]
throughout the
and general hammond so then he's forced
to retire
and then mayborn
about a week later um
recruits him to the evil sg1 king
and these guys go run around
and steal
technology that these cultures did not
release to the sg team
it's like the only reasons that the
pyramids of egypt are still in giza is
because the brits couldn't haul them
back to london
yeah no we entered everything outside
this whole thing is a ruse
to um
and it was
the tollen and um
the asgard
and um
to in general hammond
to um
find out who was stealing stuff from
uh who who the perpetrators were who
this last ops team was
and mayborne was at the center
and of course they made one gets put in
jail but the reason i liked it was
there's a little bit of espionage and
maybe again [ __ ] up and gets tossed in
jail for treason
and just a few episodes later
jack has to go fish him out of prison
and he escapes in margaritaville
but i think he did like this i mean it
really sets mayborn up as
kind of
faust
you know
i mean he's the devil you have to deal
with he's the one you have to bargain
and i thought that was kind of like he
is
he is the
his character harris you haven't seen
the episode so you don't know but his
character becomes quite important in
quite a few episodes later on in the
series and he is just that
slightly lovable rogue or a guy you love
to hate
and
he's just a completely selfish little
turd to be honest but
um
everything he touches goes wrong
eventually and that's one of the
beautiful things about it no none of his
plans work out the thing i liked in this
episode the most though chaser gray was
that the the whole setup of the um
of the ruse of the the trap was
completely believable
all the way through you going well
obviously jack isn't going to have to
retire and there must be something going
on or it's going to you know he's going
to realize but all the way through
you're not thinking oh this is out of
character you know like a lot of these
sort of episodes you're like why is he
doing that which is completely out of
character all the way going this is
completely in character i can't believe
jack hasn't done this sooner
you know
um
so that's why i loved it like that and
then when i had the twist like
two-thirds of the way through it was
actually genuinely like oh my god
you know like it was actually a twist
most stopped watching the episode the
first time i was like why is jack doing
all this stuff and of course we figured
out pretty quick but
ah it does they do a really good job of
convincing you
yeah it's uh it's it's it's just it's
absolutely brilliant episode it's really
really clever
um and then obviously that we we get the
nid sorted out and that's um that that's
a good episode as well because i did
love the nid area 51 episode from um
season two
um before we talk if we want to talk
about maybelline a bit more should we go
through a couple of other episodes that
are very important because we did
mention or storm we did mention the
hasis
in the earlier uh a little bit earlier
um the harthesis is
an important part of this series
particularly in the maternal instinct
episode at the end
where we see
the ancients for the first time
um they never say it's the ancients but
the
wispy
design and how they shape it that is how
we see the ancients every other time
later
yes so oh my god
hey we don't have the technical
difficulties
let's look real close uh we're back
we're back uh my wife eyes
oh there he is
um so she is an ancient
so and that's who we see in this episode
we see
the ancients for the first time and i've
just completely ruined the rest of the
series for you so there's no point
watching it um so yes she's nature so i
mean that's that's cool um i like that i
like that whole episode because i liked
all the uh
i like the little chinese fella and then
in the sand and everything and all the
and and daniel
learning that
taking his first step towards maybe
ascending one day that's like
as he does repeatedly
um every five minutes as we get to later
episode
um
but yeah what did you think about the
harshest's
overall story because it came into two
or three episodes in the series
um
the the favorite thing i liked about the
horses
was the um
little uh buddhist monkish
kid
you know with all these uh sayings and
absolutely indecipherable
in the center
i want to know who wrote his lines for
that episode because they think
whoever wrote those lines for that
episode did damn well with him
they googled a lot didn't they on that
one yeah well there wasn't google bank
google that's what probably might have
needed to use books
yeah they would have written
actually read stuff
but
um i i was
i like the mrc storyline i like how it
ended daniel's
journey
um trying to find his wife and trying to
find you know um and
and i think it it was quite a cruel
twist
that they then played
on him um the earlier episode uh
oh god i can't find it now
where the hell he says are forever in
clay i
didn't like that episode particularly i
thought it was a bit boring but in the
whole actually i think the heart ceases
storyline
it's kind of irrelevant does that ever
even come back
do we ever see the harshest again
uh you know sometimes i wonder if it was
just a red herring to introduce the
ancestors that was one hell of a
path take to get the grand sex there's
actually
i don't think it
does um which is which does make you
feel like that was an awful lot of
emotional
abuse of daniel
no reason really
um because it never really it doesn't i
don't think it's ever even mentioned
again that daniel's got a half it's
almost not really his son is it but his
wife's son is wandering around and we
promise to take care of but
hey i mean you know let's face it
and but it does introduce the ancients
and it does give us a bit of a
foundation in the ancients i suppose
there is that yes um a couple of other
episodes that really stood out for me
uh point of view it was episode six of
the series the mirror episode
oh
with sam with long hair
it was very pretty i like santa monica i
like summer shorter i just like sound
like
yes
um but i i thought that was really nice
and we got um
how his name's gone
died in the first episode came from the
movie they played the same um
soccer
no i won't say kazinsky but that's not
right oh uh uh sergeant
kowalski kowalski kowalski kowalski
52 area 51 guard and uh
yeah there you go so he he came back um
so quartz goes in again which is
brilliant
um it was just a really good episode i
really liked it i liked how they were
like flicking through
they like it and daniel had the remote
control and just to flick through the
universes and he's like oh that's the
one no no no i'm the wrong rank damn it
um that was a really good episode i love
that episode um that made the sound
right here happy because that's not just
multiverses that they're going through
that's like
they potentially introduce micro verses
in like the seventh dimension as well
and maybe even more than that so that's
that gets really
really science to go fast i don't i
doubt they
explore that too much further
anywhere else but uh
well they did but it wasn't in this
universe
yeah they researched the hell out of it
another universe
probably
um
you sneaky bugger
um
sorry
a couple of the episodes that run
through this quite a lot though was the
satan episodes wasn't it and that goes
through to the there's the whole so car
and uh
those are the these are episodes for me
again
[Music]
it was just a bit dull and i didn't i
didn't think they went
and the so-called
guy they had to play so car
wasn't scary
he he looked a bit
he looked like if he was if he lived
next door you'd really watch where your
children were if he was about
um he's just like you don't want him
near that guy
that guy's getting strange
um don't come look at my puppy no
um but i'm not scared of him so i didn't
really like that character um
but those whole episodes were just
a bit random i thought
what did you guys think
yeah
there for a while it seems like they
just you know
uh got the catalog of egyptian deities
and just started knocking off knocking
them off you just have somebody you know
it was the egyptian god death of the
week or something you know
because you didn't chew through them for
a while you know it's like okay but
still apocalypse killing
videotaping oh he's in the next episode
those episodes were about a positive
apocalypse though for me they built so
car because this terrifying character
and then they just didn't do it
it became about a profit
i'm like
you've just built up satan and he's not
really in it
he's not all that satanic you know
no it's not good they did the book of
boba fett and bubble fact wasn't in it
for two days it's just like
it's like wait where's where's soccer
where's satan
um
but but yeah it's just
[ __ ] really
um
though they did tie up all the loose
ends didn't they i think from the movie
so scarra's story in the episode and
pretense was also
tied up tied up in a really nice way
actually having that that the toll and
had that court case basically to decide
which being deserved to live was it
scarra or was it corral
um and i i liked it that's a clever
that's the one things about stargate
that i love is that they never do
anything the way you expect them to do
it
that was uh i i really like that
storyline
but again that just tied up
that storyline and you know
so between that between chad
and and scarra oldham
which throws me off that they don't
bring the harasses child back into play
at any point after all this stuff if
that's like kind of the last time they
say it a little alert lately i can't
even speak right now a little later in
the season
uh
that's such an odd choice you'd think
it'd be so much more pivotal but if it
introduces the ancients it does its job
yeah maybe they'll bring it back for the
new series maybe that's brad wright's
thinking but um
oh
one episode i absolutely loved but not
for any other reason then um cannonball
run with burt reynolds was one of my
favorite films when i was a kids and don
deluise
is just brilliant in it um and then we
have the episode ergo
which again was a slightly random
episode it was a fun episode but
i'd love tommy
it's just great it's
so cool it was fun though yeah yeah his
character and the
propeller character and it might have my
two
just like one-off episodes sort of thing
um i just loved ergo he's
annoyingly hilarious a bit like stormy
and so
but he's just he's just fantastic and i
just thought it was growing
um but there are some good episodes in
this but i mean
the hundred days episode where
um
o'neil meets
lara and he falls in love with it that
was a bit boring if i'm honest
um
new ground was a bit boring i got the
dominar's memory it's a bit boring
it's just there are a few episodes in
this this season that i
didn't i didn't i didn't think a lot of
i skipped
do you think some of those episodes were
there like
like o'neill fallen in love was
literally do you think they wrote that
as almost an excuse for the next episode
because they knew what they wanted to do
with mayborn and him i kind of fill him
in the blanks almost
because they had 22 episodes to fill in
some blanks
yeah there's always a couple of filler
episodes in there and i mean they do use
that storyline in the next
in the next video that's why that's how
jack gets an excuse to go through the
gate
um
so i mean they do use that episode so i
i don't know maybe it was a bit chicken
egg or you know like carp full of horses
and thinking that they they
wouldn't have thought they would set up
an entire episode just to do that but
they have to but
yeah well you know it may have just been
one of those lucky coincidences you know
uh unplanned uh positive circumstance
hey let's use it because if you think
about to go through the the catalog of
episodes
there's plenty of other places jack you
know
would have just wanted to be off worlds
you know
um
[Music]
the uh the episode foothold
was one of the um was a good episode as
well
um and we got to meet a couple of new
recruits and we got to see a bit more
about how the sgc works
um but to me it was just like it was one
of those you know the sci-fi movies they
do it all the time they did it like
avengers and all sorts that um you have
an impossible army
impossible defeat but it's okay because
all you have to do is like defeat the
one hive mind and the rest will just die
and fall asleep and they kind of did
that with foothold
and um i know kind of i always find that
a little bit lazy but um
it's a clever enough episode i just
thought it was a bit they'd done it
before
sort of thing
and they'll do it again
again or it could have been just another
excuse for me to screw up
yeah and again well maybe one screwed up
in that one as either yeah
judah khan just talked about joe lenar's
memories and how that's just good
character development for sam and the
topra and then uh jacob carter storyline
that was honestly one of the
the good subplots of season three i i
did enjoy it yeah i i did i i found the
episode as a whole boring but you're
right it does build up the whole sam
relationship with the dad
um
and
yeah i think i do think that's important
and
that they had a
difficult relationship but they were
trying to rebuild that relationship and
um
and and we learned more about the tokra
as well so i mean it it added to the to
the general
story and the plot and the background of
stargate
i just found the episode a little slow i
think
it's a little stale but
but it's important to watch and these
are the episodes you can't skip or
you'll never have a bloody clue
what did you guys think of the ground
i don't think they're it doesn't seem i
mean i'm only four seasons in just the
beginning it doesn't seem like they're
really episodes
maybe in the future
but uh
i wouldn't skip anything because even if
you um he's gone
he's going to eat
but even if even if you skip an episode
someone's about they'll say something
that will come back that's important
yeah
but this is also the greatest sci-fi
show ever made so don't skip anything
what are you thinking
i wasn't thinking there was anything
skippable
what did you guys think of the crystal
skull episode
yeah
tweet about it because i laughed because
they did crystal school better than
spielberg 10 years before spielberg
decided
daniel jackson would have a crazy
grandfather that was also ostriched from
ostracized from the community
it's like of course daniel's
grandfather's ostracized
life thank you
christine had a mental ground it
actually taught us a lot about why
daniel was daniel at the start of the
movie there wasn't his own way in these
crazy ideas
um
and um
and yeah i said i
it's not my favorite episode i'm gonna
i'm not gonna lie it's um
again
a bit boring
um
yeah but it's real building and it and
and we learned something new about
daniel which is which is always good i
always love it when you learn something
new about the characters but
so like the agents do we get to see
those aliens again down the road
rumors that there may be related to the
furling somehow some people believe
um
which is um
[Music]
another one of the the one of the alien
races that we don't ever really get to
see
but they get into that a few times those
are those ewok looking ones huh
they're not no
yeah well yes and no
um in an episode jack is basically
dreaming
um and he mentions the feelings and
that's what he thinks that's what
o'neill believes they would look like
so he thinks feelings they're going to
be furry right so he thinks they look
like the ewoks and we don't ever
actually see them
interesting
there's a couple there's an atlantis
episode where we think we see them
um but it doesn't actually say it's them
uh there's an episode with the the
daedalus is captured and all the crew
are being away and um and it just does
that it's a test
and by this ancient alien species so
it's implied heavily that's the feelings
and there's another episode as well
and there's nine but uh
and but we never actually see them so
yeah that time we see them
it's it's it's that's that's just
o'neill's brain
hey it makes my star wars self happy
yeah i better give you a little star
wars happy didn't it
um
so yeah
series 3 then in a nutshell
not the best series in the world but
well it it it batters up
season four
which
is an astonishing series
i mean if you talk about this being a
great episode
series four episode one um i i remember
watching it new
um when it first came out and i remember
just being absolutely blown away but it
was just like [ __ ] i think that's when i
absolutely fell in love with stargate
and never looked back i was like screw
you star trek
um what do you guys think and then like
in a nutshell
yeah
well it was okay i think if we uh
stargate turned out to be a short time
series
i think we'd be saying well you know
season three was pretty good i did it
all with this [ __ ]
yeah but because we got such astonishing
great content later on
you know the the average quality went up
to the high
we now see uh
uh season three as
less than less than
the rest of this year it seems to be a
local
because just just coming from like a
whole fresh point of view again and
watching it all and
season three wasn't amazing but also
like i said just i i like to world build
i'm a fan of all these different things
i like to write myself sometimes and uh
from like a writing perspective it feels
like it sets the stage going forward and
judicon says it does for the whole
series so i'm i'm going with you
yeah
i i would argue that that it's it's one
of those things
this is why sg-1 in particular was so
brilliant was because it was always
really good at reinventing itself
and building on what it had already done
and and growing
and this is just that this is just a
perfect example of that that yeah okay
compared to what came afterwards it's
not the best season in the world but to
be there neither was season one or two
uh one note here um
but it just kept growing in this season
we tied up all the loose ends from the
movie
we sort of put that stargate behind us
and we went into the next phase of
stargate where the replicators became
more of a concern than the gold wools
really
um
i think this is when the gold will
all of a sudden are not considered the
threat that they were
you know it's like um
all of a sudden
the towers world has got a lot bigger
you know and it's just this is the
season that that it gets big
and but start sg-1 particularly
reinvented itself so many times
um obviously i mean
no more more so than in series nine and
ten where it completely reinvented
itself
um
that series could have gone on forever
so good we lost it i i like that
reinvention though it really
i mean a lot of kind of 90s and early
2000s shows didn't necessarily
they were cheesy in their own ways and
this is cheesy in a lot of ways but it's
also very humanizing by like reinventing
people not just every season but halfway
through the season you learn some
pivotal information that really changes
like the dynamic of like like sam carter
with her dad and daniel jackson with the
whole heart cess event just every little
time that's even brought up it just
mentally changes daniel and you see like
the the remnants of that in each episode
and i'm not i'm a fan i like it i i'm
excited to see where it will continue to
reinvent itself
you're going to start looking serious
for
because no she i don't want to throw
anybody off no spoilers i guess
also we're a little late for spoilers
here uh
season four the second you just said uh
the the replicators kind of become the
forefront of the threat compared to the
good old
they get those armbands i just watched
the episode with the armbands and the
three of them daniel jackson carter and
uh o'neill just take out apophis entire
they essentially just built that new
ship
almost akin to how the asgard just built
that new phantom ship to take out the
replicators and then in about 10 minutes
or 15 minutes to be exact uh
that thing's blown up and gone
which is great it shows you that it's
they're leveling up a little bit
yeah i'd agree with that yeah
um
but
going into season four i think it's um
it was it was a great series i loved it
when it came out it's just got looking
back on it isn't it so
that is season three really sorted
um some great episodes some lots of
great episodes but you can skip
um you can't skip many in this one
though because it keeps telling you
stuff that you really need to know for
later episodes but
like say introduction of
the replicators
um the the in many ways the least
terrifying bad guy in the planet because
you never see them actually hurt anyone
it's always door closes you hear screams
from the other side of me and actually
you kind of think like
how scary are they but actually they're
[ __ ] brilliant
and it's
just another time then stargate comes up
with a completely new villain that's
just brilliant
so fantastic all right then we've
stormy we're done early
excuse me was it last minute yeah we're
done early
yeah normally you drag this out to like
an hour and 20 minutes until my wife is
ready to divorce me
well because i can't talk
it's too appalling
to irritate me
but guys thank you so much for joining
we can wrap this one up nice and easy
because we didn't really talk about
mainboard a great deal but
yeah i mean it is a nutshell and i don't
want to ruin it too much for you harris
but every time we see him he screws
something up
he seems like
almost presented in a way as like an
anti-hero to a degree right i feel like
he's more of like an anti-villain in a
way or he's always trying to do some
more kind of personal gains and some bad
[ __ ] for the most part and then
kind of has to help out every now and
then
buddy movies where it's like a cop movie
and they they're they're supposed to
love each other but really they just
hate each other and they just think
that's o'neill and mayborn particularly
in the later episodes except o'neill
never does the love bit he just hates
him
um and it's just that's always the same
thing
and he won't have to say he has to save
his life in a later episode when he
becomes king of uh his own planet
um but especially
o'neal at one point in time asked
hammond
to help him retrieve his soul at one
point because
yeah it messes everything up but thank
you guys and stormy thank you so much
for joining us mate when you are really
really not well
um
thank you yeah i dude i really enjoyed
it at least i got to talk to somebody
oh that's a good point instead of just
the wall
[Laughter]
everybody
yeah yeah
yeah harris thank you again and let's
let's show off your spinning jumper just
before we go
available
see the quality the quality you modeling
look at you showing off um but thank you
this this t-shirt's available as well
and stormy i don't want to ruin things
but you know i said i was going to get
you something a little thank you
yeah i might have accidentally forgot to
pay for it
so um
but it's coming now
so hopefully next time we see you
you will have your gift and you can show
you can show something off
all right
i just went into it stormy hasn't
mentioned that it should have arrived by
now so i went on the website and it was
still sat in there the
checkout
[ __ ] and favorite
so you have a little thank you on its
way
and and harris don't buy anything else
off psylotrek.com
because just let me know
i will send it you
okay thank you
thank you
i've got like three
excellent don't forget guys if you're
new to the channel like subscribe hit
the bell notification and more
importantly go over to stormy and
cyworks and subscribe there and harris
on and
where he does brilliant videos i'll
share them on the channel as well when i
can be bothered um and yeah get over
there and show them some sidetrack love
guys
stormy get well yes
i'll get covered i don't think he can
catch it through um
through the internet but just in case
the internet has been playing up so
maybe
get in both of us i better not i'm going
to be in costa rica in three days so i'm
not staying healthy
damn it man go to costa rica you're in
vegas last week
ah i'll bring my camera and microphone
we'll be good i i got my laptop with me
i'm just like
i wish i was young again but anyway all
right guys
have fun we'll see you really soon oh no
i'm about to hit the wrong thing
see you later champs
[Music]